[Music]
i'm christopher hein
and this week we're talking about a
timmy in aikido what is a timmy nikita
it's a known cliche in aikido that
the founders said aikido is 90 percent
of timmy or some great number
of uh timmy and a timmy means to hit the
body so that makes aikido sound like
it's a striking system
and what does that mean in this video
we're going to talk about why i believe
uh the founders said that aikido is 90
striking and what that really means um
and i'll get josh over here and i think
we can clarify
it pretty quick for you josh
okay so this is the end of our week here
on uh atemi and the classic strikes in
aikido and what those guys are all about
so really important to understand is
ikea uh has been said in the past by the
founders to be
90 a timmy or uh somewhere there about
you know so a large significant portion
you hear different people
quote different percentages he said but
the idea is that he said that the
majority of
aikido is a timmy and what does that
mean so atemi in japanese means to
strike the body with something to hit
the body
so in aikido we are basically playing
what i
nowadays would call a contact game okay
meaning that
josh's whole game and what i'm trying to
resist is josh's ability to make contact
with me
now unlike boxing i'm not interested
necessarily in making contact back with
him now i might i might use a weapon or
something to hit him to get him away to
go away from me
but my goal is not to get the hit my
goal is to out distance
him so he cannot make contact with me so
of aikido is this guy trying to make
contact right so let's say i'm attacking
josh
right now what are the ways i'm going to
make contact with josh well
i could just walk up to him and grab
them now that's not going to be very
easy in our aikido context because when
i walk up to grab this guy
he's going to start making distance
right so josh's going to make distance
that's going to be hard
so when he's making that distance what
am i going to do to compensate for that
well i'm either going to quickly run in
or i'm going to take a big
lunging shot of some sort so meaning i
come to get this guy and he moves
i'm either going to be faster than him
so i'm going to run faster he's going to
run faster i'm going to see if i catch
him
or i'm going to take a lunging action
right so what are lunging actions
lunging actions are either
me throwing myself in here to shove him
like that
or me throwing some kind of big strike
in some way to get this guy right so i'm
going to
lunge after him so aikido practice
is really for the most part dealing with
someone trying to make contact with your
body
and that contact could be a grab as well
right so that could be a grab
i've just made contact with josh i've
hit josh's body in a way i've got a hold
of them right
so any anything in aikido is is mostly
about
studying how to keep someone from making
that contact with me so
ninety percent of iq to practice is
about learning just that how do i keep
someone from making contact
now that doesn't mean that i want to get
them back in fact in aikido i don't want
to get anyone back i don't care about
hurting anyone else my goal is never
hurt someone in ikea i just don't want
them to hurt me
now sometimes as a repercussion of
everything happening
i might end up hurting someone else but
that's not what i want that's not my
goal that was
a bad eye key right so i didn't have
good idea in order to do it but
mostly what we're dealing with is me
lunging in to get somebody so josh got
to have ways to blend with that so he
could get out of the way of that right
or me trying to take some kind of big
shot he's got to have some way of
dealing with that right so
and get himself out of there after that
so understand that when we say
aikido is the majority about a timmy
it's not about
me hitting someone else it's about
someone else trying to hit me and me
keeping them from doing that so
i'm judging how that's working so aikido
is asymmetrical works on one side so my
whole goal is not to get the other guy
but to keep him from getting me and
generally the way i'm going to do that
is some kind of way that keeps us at
distance so what's he going to try and
do
make contact over and over and over i'm
christopher hine thanks for watching